PROFESSOR: OK.
So what I want to do in the
first part of this lecture is
just finish our discussion of
liberty from last time,
beginning by saying a couple
of additional clarificatory
things about the particular
pages from Nozick that we
read, and then moving on to
explaining what I think is an
important way that Nozick and
Rawls are confronting one of
the problems that each of the
thinkers that we have
addressed has confronted,
namely, the problem of luck in
determining human experience.
And when we finish that we'll
move on to the two empirical
readings that we
did for today.
So you'll recall that in the
pages of Nozick that we read,
Nozick is concerned, first of
all, to present a general
framework for thinking about
political philosophy in a
context which prioritizes
liberty and rights.
And, in particular, in the
pages that we read from
chapter seven, concerned with
articulating a view about the
legitimacy of the ownership of
property that takes as its
principal justification
only three parts.
The first, you recall, is
Nozick's discussion of the
notion of justice
in acquisition.
And we talked last time about
the conditions under which
Nozick thinks it's legitimate
for somebody
to come to own property.
And the basic idea there is that
it is legitimate to take
something from common stock that
is unowned so long as in
so doing one doesn't
violate what Nozick
calls the Lockean Proviso.
That is, so long as one leaves
"as much and as good for
others."
And we considered two objections
to that view.
One, the idea that there's a
kind of unzipping that occurs
that makes even the first
acquisition illegitimate if
the property ultimately
runs out.
And the second based on the
problem of the commons, that
regardless there's going to be
a time at which somebody
appears to be disadvantaged by
another taking ownership, and
talked about Nozick's
responses to them.
And it's my hope that in
sections this week you'll have
a chance to think through
whether those responses are
legitimate.
We looked next at Nozick's views
on justice in transfer,
which are basically that any
transfer that two people are
willing to engage in is a
legitimate sort of transfer.
It is an illegitimate
restriction on people's
freedom, on Nozick's view, to
restrict what it is that you
are permitted to do with
your property.
But Nozick recognizes--
and we didn't get to this in
our lecture on Tuesday--
that in addition there's
a need for a
third sort of notion.
And this is the idea that
sometimes property is
illegitimately acquired, either
initially or as a
result of an illegitimate
transfer.
And that with regard to that,
one is required, on his view,
to engage in some sort
of rectification.
And this idea gives rise to a
rather striking passage at the
very end of the chapter, which
we read for last week.
Nozick writes there that as a
matter of fact there have been
previously in the acquisition
of property
incidences of injustice.
This nation, for example, was
founded on black slavery.
And Nozick notes that those from
the least well off group
in society right now have the
highest probabilities of being
the descendants of victims of
the most serious injustice.
As a consequence, he says,
perhaps the following rule of
thumb is a reasonable one
for us to make use of.
Perhaps we ought to do what
Rawls suggests and organize
society to benefit the
least well off.
Past injustices, says Nozick,
may be so great as to make
necessary in the short run a
more extensive state than the
one that Nozick has
been advocating in
order to rectify them.
Page 231, Anarchy, State, and
Utopia, telling us that
perhaps a good rule of thumb
is to organize society to
benefit the least well off.
So do Nozick and Rawls
agree after all?
Well notice what Nozick
argued earlier.
Even if we engage in this
temporary act of
reorganization, liberty
upsets patterns.
So give everybody the same sized
piggy bank, give them
the freedom to do what they want
with their quarters, and
it will inevitably become the
case that some are better off
than others.
Moreover, as we noted at the end
of our lecture last time,
these distributions of wealth
may end up having
consequences, where deciding
whether they violate at least
the spirit of the Lockean
Proviso becomes a rather
difficult question to answer.
We noted at the end of our
lecture last time that there
might be a society in which
there's an equal distribution
of wealth across individuals and
a social interaction among
them with regard to the
institutions that prepare
people to become democratic
citizens.
But if, as our last slide
demonstrated, it is inevitable
that such a structure will
ultimately result in an
unequal distribution of wealth,
and if an unequal
distribution of wealth brings
with it the freedom of opting
out of certain public
institutions, creating private
ones from which one may draw
away resources that once
belonged to the public
institutions, then
particularly in the case of
things like education and
health, which one might think
are preconditions for
participation in democracy, it
becomes complicated to think
through whether those sorts of
distributions are justified.
So the Nozick picture presents
us with an idea of what sorts
of actions are permitted.
It seems for a moment as if
Nozick agrees with Rawls that
a certain kind of redistribution
is permitted.
But ultimately there isn't the
leverage within the framework,
in at least an obvious
sense, to avoid
situations like this one.
Now it's an open question
whether one takes it as a
priority to avoid situations
like this one.
But it is a striking fact of
both A Theory of Justice and
Anarchy, State, and Utopia, that
a look at their indexes
produces no references to
education, no references to
childhood and only limited
awareness of the topic, which
will be central to our
discussion today.
Namely the ways in which the
social structures that
surround us end up affecting
what sorts of preferences we
have in addition to what sorts
of choices we make.
Now you'll remember that the
fundamental question, which
underlies the debate about
what makes a particular
structure in society legitimate
is the one
articulated by Rawls in the
beginning of Theory of
Justice, which I placed for you
as the second essay topic
for the final set of essays.
Rawls points out that a society
is "a cooperative
venture for mutual advantage
typically marked by conflict
as well as identity of
interests," and notes,
following Hobbes in the social
contract tradition, that
there's an identity of
interests in special
cooperation that makes possible
a better life than
anybody could have without
cooperation.
But a conflict of interests,
since people are not
indifferent to how those
goods are distributed.
Now at some level we can
conceive of one aspect of the
debate between Rawls and Nozick,
where Rawls says, if
things come out patterned in a
way that behind the veil of
ignorance you wouldn't want
them to, intervene and
redistribute.
Whereas Nozick says, if things
come out as the result of free
actions between free
individuals, then regardless
of what that pattern looks
like, accept it.
One can view that difference in
outlook between them as a
difference in outlook about how
we are morally required to
deal with the fact that in so
far as things that affect us
occur, determining what is and
is not in our control, in so
far as it matters for our own
internal reactions to events,
as Epictetus pointed out.
In so far as it matters to our
tendency to respond in keeping
with our commitments, as
Aristotle and Doris in Doris's
debate with Aristotle
questioned.
And in so far as it covers our
attribution of praise and
blame in cases of unintended
wrongdoing or right-doing,
which the discussions of moral
luck and punishment and Kant
versus Mill on whether there's
moral merit to saving a child.
In all of these cases, the
fundamental question that's
being asked is this: what sort
of stance is the appropriate
stance for human beings to take,
given that as Epictetus
says, "some things are up to us
and other things are not up
to us?"
So if we look at Rawls's Theory
of Justice, we read the
following striking passages.
Rawls says, "The two principles
mentioned," that is
the first principle which says
rights are untrumpable,
roughly speaking, every
individual is entitled to
certain basic freedoms,
which no amount
of utility can override.
And the second principle, which
says, inequalities are
to be distributed as the result
of offices which are
equally open to all and in such
a way that inequalities
are to the benefit of
the least well off.
Rawls says, "The two principles
mentioned seem to
be a fair agreement on the basis
of which those better
endowed or more fortunate in
their social position neither
of which we can be said to
deserve, could expect the
willing cooperation of others
when some workable scheme is a
necessary condition of
the welfare of all."
Or again, "once we decide to
look for a conception of
justice that nullifies the
accidents of natural endowment
and the contingencies of
social circumstance as
counters in quest for political
and economic
advantage, we are lead
to these principles."
Or again, "these principles
express the result of leaving
aside those aspects of more
social world that seem
arbitrary from a moral
point of view --
things we cannot be
said to deserve."
Accidents of natural endowment.
Contingencies of social
circumstance.
Aspects of social world that
seem arbitrary from a moral
point of view.
Rawls is engaged in the ancient
project of thinking
about how to deal
with moral luck.
And because the distribution
of goods and advantages--
both within the self and
between selves--
is not in many ways up to us,
Rawls concludes that the
principles that he articulates
in Theory of Justice are what
justice mandates.
Nozick, by contrast, is also
concerned with luck.
Let's look at the passages at
the end of chapter seven.
Here, says Nozick, talking about
Rawls's writing, we have
Rawls' reason for rejecting a
system of natural liberty.
It permits distributive shares
to be improperly influenced by
factors that are so arbitrary
from a moral point of view.
Nozick says, Rawls is trying
to deal with the problem of
moral luck.
These factors, he says, quoting
Rawls, are "prior
distribution of natural talents
and abilities as these
have been developed over time
by social circumstances and
such chance contingencies as
accident and good fortune."
Notice, says Nozick, that Rawls
is concerned with things
that are not up to us.
But there is, says Nozick, no
mention at all of how persons
have chosen to develop their
own natural assets.
And it's in recognition of the
counterpart oh some things
being not up to us-- namely
the fact that some
things are up to us--
that we can see Nozick's notion
of legitimate dessert
in light of this
eternal debate.
This line of argument, says
Nozick in criticism of Rawls,
can succeed in blocking the
introduction of a person's
autonomous choices and actions
and their results only by
attributing everything
noteworthy about the person to
certain kinds of external
factors.
But, says Nozick, if we start
thinking about people as
defined by their circumstances
in the way that a logical
extension of this view would
suggest, but says Nozick,
"Denigrating a person's
autonomy and prime
responsibility for his actions
is a risky in line for a
theory that otherwise wishes
to buttress the dignity and
self-respect of autonomous
beings."
We're back to our fundamental
question.
Given that we are beings
influenced by the world around
us in ways which it is
extraordinarily difficult to
understand, to what extent do
we deserve credit for that
which we perceive ourselves
to have done voluntarily?
And to what extent are our
characters and circumstances
so inextricably linked with
things beyond our control that
thinking from the perspective of
us as willers of structure
in the world is a mistake
all together?
So I want to point out to you
that what started out as
looking like a debate about
the legitimacy of taxation
ends up looking like
one of our central
philosophical debates.
Again and again we're confronted
with our status as
beings in the world that
we both affect and
are affected by.
So that theme in two particular
empirical articles
is what I want to address in the
remaining thirty minutes
of lecture in the context
of our social structures
discussion.
So remember that in this
political philosophy unit we
began with a reading of
Hobbes's Leviathan and
encountered his argument that
because of certain facts about
human nature-- basically our
desire to control goods around
us and the limitation
in the number of
goods that there are--
we will in a state of
nature be in a war
of all against all.
And then we looked at a
mathematical representation of
that in the form of Prisoners'
Dilemma and then considered
two particular responses in
the 20th century Western
Anglo-American philosophical
tradition--
namely Rawls and Nozick--
to think through what a
legitimate society looks like
in the context of facts
about human nature.
What I want to do in the part
of the lecture devoted to
social structures is to bring
out you the way in which the
structures that surround us
end up determining our
attitudes at least as much
as our attitudes end up
determining the social
structures around us.
This is a theme that's present
already in Aristotle.
So in the closing pages of the
Nicomachean Ethics, which we
read about a month ago,
Aristotle, in a chapter
entitled, Transition from
Morality to Political
Philosophy, noted, you'll
recall, that "if arguments
alone were sufficient by
themselves to make people
decent the rewards that they
would command would
justifiably have been many and
large." But that "it's not
easy to alter by argument" what
has long been absorbed as
a result of one's habits.
How then, asks Aristotle, might
we go about changing
people if argument alone
is not sufficient
to make people decent?
Well, he points out, it's
difficult for somebody to be
trained correctly from his youth
if he's not brought up
under correct laws.
For the young do not find
it pleasant to live in a
temperate way." That is why
one of the things on this
ancient picture of governance,
one of the things the law must
prescribe is their upbringing
and practices.
For if they are used to behaving
in certain ways they
will not find them painful.
So Aristotle is talking about
a function of law that will
occupy us both today
and Thursday --
the function of law in shaping
the character of the citizens
who are governed thereby.
But it's not just in Aristotle
that we find this theme.
John Stuart Mill, author of the
famous work On Liberty and
also author of Utilitarianism,
which we read for this class,
makes much the same point
as Aristotle.
He writes, in talking about
how to structure society
appropriately, so as to maximize
the amount of utility
that it produces, he says
"utility enjoins that first
that laws and social
arrangements should place the
happiness--
or as speaking practically it
may be called the interest--
of every individual as nearly
as possible in harmony with
the interests of the whole."
A well-structured society on
Mill's view manages the
relation between the individual
and the community.
And utility enjoins in keeping
with that, says Mill, that
"education and opinion, which
have so vast a power over
human character, should so use
that power as to establish in
the mind of every individual and
indissoluble association
between his own happiness and
the good of the whole."
"Education and opinion, which
have so vast a power over
human character." That's the
theme of today's lecture.
And in about four slides will
have clickers because it's
late in the semester and I
want you guys to wake up.
So if you get your clickers out
I'll tell you some facts
and then you can tell
me some responses.
All right.
So the first piece that we
read for today is a long
survey article from the journal
Behavioral and Brain
Sciences, in which the authors
survey a century's worth of
anthropological and
psychological research in an
attempt to bring empirical force
to the claim that Mill
makes here --
that education and opinion,
cultural structures, have a
vast power over human
character.
The authors argue in this paper
that subjects, whom they
call WEIRD, that is Western,
educated, industrialized,
rich, democratic, citizens --
people who have been brought
into consciousness in a
society which has these
five features.
They argue that these subjects
are atypical, that is, differ
in fundamental ways in their
attitude towards the world if
you contrast them with subjects
who come from small
scale non-industrialized
societies, if you contrast
them with individuals who come
from non-Western industrial
societies, if you contrast them
with individuals who come
from other Western
industrialized societies, and
even if you contrast them with
other citizens of their own
nation who are not university
educated.
In particular, claim the
authors, the domains in which
we can see the weirdness--
in small letters--
of the WEIRD-- in large--
that is the atypicality
of Western, educated,
industrialized, rich,
democratic, citizens include,
they contend, perception,
categorization, memory,
attention, spatial cognition,
self concepts, judgments of
fairness, tendencies towards
cooperation, tendencies
towards conformity, moral
judgments and so on.
In a vast number of
domains, you--
including those of you who are
not from Western cultures--
differ from the vast majority
of the 6 or 7 billion other
people on Earth.
And certainly from the vast
majority of those who have
lived on Earth throughout
time.
As a result of the cultural
experiences you have had, your
perception and apprehension and
patterns of attention have
been affected.
So the authors wrote their
article with a
particular goal in mind.
They wrote it in an effort to
argue that psychological
research of the sort which fills
journals, including the
one in which they published this
piece, should be based on
broader population samples.
And they make this argument
because they're concerned both
with the possibility of
revealing differences among
human beings, ways in which
people raised in one sort of
circumstance differ from people
raised in another.
And because they are profoundly
concerned with also
identifying the ways in which
there are commonalities.
And you'll notice as you read
through the article that each
of the four main sections
begins with a series of
contrasts between WEIRD folks
and whatever the contrast
group is, but closes with
a set of identified
commonalities between the two
groups, suggesting at least
prima facie that there are
deep-seeded similarities,
presumably the result of
evolutionary pressures.
But this is not a course in
evolutionary psychology.
This isn't even specifically a
course in the methodology of
psychology.
So why did we read
this article?
Four reasons that we read it.
The first is that this is a
course, as you know, called
Philosophy and the Science
of Human Nature.
And this article, perhaps more
densely than any article I can
think of, contains a vast number
of extraordinarily cool
facts about ways people
might be.
So the first reason we read the
article is just to learn
some facts about human diversity
and similarity.
In addition, as you know,
this is an "and" course.
This is a course, as you will
recall from the very first
lecture, that's tries to bring
together different
perspectives on questions.
And one of the things that
I think this article does
beautifully, in particular in
conjunction with the second
article that we read for today,
is to give you a range
of tools for thinking about
central questions.
One of the things that the
article challenges you to do
when you observe a behavior and
make a generalization on
its basis is to ask yourself
how generalizable really is
that behavior?
But this is also a course, and
this is the third reason we
read the article, that
introduces you, as you know,
to a dead guy on Tuesday and
CogSci on Thursday, today
being an honorary Thursday.
So the third thing that the
article does is to make you
aware of a live critique, one
posed just last year -- the
article was published less
than 12 months ago --
to make you aware of a critique
that attaches itself
to part of the course's
research base.
One of the things that we have
been doing throughout the
semester, one of the things
that all of you did in
directed exercise five, was to
take a look at some of the
articles, whose limited
samplings are being challenged
in this piece.
Finally, we're reading this
piece in the context of our
political philosophy section
in a lecture called social
structures because it seems to
me crucial, if one wants to
engage in serious political
philosophy, to bring out the
complex range of considerations
that need to go
into thinking about how
societies ought to be
structured.
So what I want to do in the next
part of the lecture is to
run through three examples of
the sorts of cases with which
the WEIRD article
is concerned.
Three cases where a claim is
made that experience has
affected how it is that you
perceive the world.
And I start with their
most dramatic.
Perhaps not the most
well established.
We'll talk about it.
But the most dramatic of their
claims. So I'd like you to
take out your clickers and look
at these things here.
And tell me, to you whether the
two segments appear to be
such that the top is shorter
than the bottom or it could be
such that they are of
the same length.
We're talking about just
the line segments here.
Or it could be such
that the bottom is
shorter than the top.
And we'll take 10, 9, 8, 7, 6,
4, 3, 2, 1 second to see how
these numbers come out.
So 41% of you think it appears
that the top is shorter than
the bottom.
46% of you, it appears that
they are the same length.
Whereas 14% are such that
the bottom appears
shorter than the top.
14% percent of you, come on
down, you are correct.
The bottom is shorter
then the top.
You want to see that again?
All right.
So what going on here?
I've got the same animation on
the next slide because I
wasn't sure you could animate
on a slide that had graphs.
But it turns out you can.
OK, so again look at these.
These are identical.
These are duplicates.
I made them, I measured them
because I have a measurement
program in PowerPoint.
So this one is actually 3.1 and
this is actually 3 inches
long in the creation.
So the bottom is shorter
than the top.
Now it has been argued that your
tendency to perceive this
line, when embedded within this
figure, as longer than
this segment when embedded in
this figure, is the result of
your having grown up
in an environment
with carpentered corners.
And the claim is made on the
basis of research done in the
1960s in a vast number of
small-scale non-urbanized
communities, that the
discrepancy between line
lengths, segment lengths,
required in order to see this
one as being the same length
as this one is extremely
different in small-scale
societies where there is
roughly, according to this
research, no tendency to be
taken in by these extensions.
To Western society--
this is Evanston, Illinois,
and South Africa--
a tendency to find this illusion
massively compelling.
Now whether or not these data
ultimately hold up, it's
complicated to determine because
the research was done
almost 50 years ago when the
tools for asking these
questions held themselves to
different standards than
people hold themselves today,
it's nonetheless not
implausible to think that
this might be true.
Experience determines
all sorts of things.
And it's not unimaginable that
among the things that it would
determine is what sorts of
perceptual features you pick
up on when encountering
a situation.
It is, at the very least,
undeniable that there are
fundamental and interesting
differences between the
tendency of those raised in
Eastern cultures and the
Western cultures to avail
themselves of the two kinds
of fundamental reasoning
processes which are available
to all of us.
So you know, both from your
readings for today and from
our readings on the dual
processing tradition earlier
in the semester, that human
beings are capable both of
what is called holistic
processing.
That is orienting towards an
object as embedded in a
context, paying attention to
relationships between the
focal object and the field that
surrounds it and having a
tendency as a result to make
predictions and offer
explanations on the basis of
these relational properties.
So that's one kind
of thinking.
And all of us have
it available.
But there is, in addition, a
second kind of thinking, which
every adult human being has
available to him and her:
analytic processing, through
which, one orients towards an
object as considered in
isolation, pays attention
primarily to the object
attributes, not to features of
its surround and exhibits a
tendency to predict and
explain events on the basis
of such attributes.
So you'll remember when we
were reading the Doris
critique of Aristotle and the
suggestion was made that it's
not features of the individual
himself, not attributes of the
object, that determine how it is
that somebody will act in a
potentially morally demanding
situation.
But rather features of his
relationship to his context.
Whether he's found a dime
in the phone booth,
whether he's in a rush.
The claim that Doris makes in
offering that critique of
Aristotle, a version of what's
called the fundamental
attribution error, is that there
are cases where analytic
processing leads us awry and
holistic processing does a
better job of explaining.
There are, likewise, cases where
focusing our attention
profoundly on the object itself
and not attending to
irrelevant features of the
environment will leave us
better off.
It is striking, given that
that there appear to be
reliable and statistically
significant differences over
time in members of Western and
non-Western cultures with
regard to which of these
attitudes they
take on as a default.
So in a series of articles that
have been written over
roughly the last decade, Richard
Nisbett and a number
of collaborators have presented
subjects with cues
like the following.
They're shown a series of fish
against a particular
background.
And then shown a series of novel
fish, either with the
same or different backgrounds.
Or a series of polar bears or
elk against a particular
background and then either
novel or previously seen
objects against either a
similar or different
background.
So what advantage do subjects
demonstrate when they see an
object that they've seen before
against a familiar
background?
For the Japanese individuals,
whom Nisbett and his
collaborators tested, an
object seen against its
original background yields
a high accuracy rate.
If you show it without a
background at all, there's
less accuracy.
And if you show it against a
novel background, there's a
striking decrement
in performance.
And again with the wolves.
If you show it against
the original
background, high accuracy.
Show it against the
novel background,
a significant decrement.
These are clean patterns.
What happens with Western
subjects?
Different pattern altogether.
Original background doesn't
help re-identification.
No background helps a lot.
The distraction of additional
information has been removed.
And a novel background doesn't
leave them much worse off than
the original.
Ditto with the wolves.
Original background produces
some, but not much, advantage.
I'm going to skip the next
example, which suggests, and
you'll be able to watch this
yourselves on the slides that
I post, that again there are
contexts in which Westerners
appear to be better at absolute
tasks, non-Westerners
at relative tasks.
Now what sort of business
do we have making these
generalizations about
cultures?
Isn't this an outrageous sort
of thing to be doing?
The claim is not that culture
determines everything about an
individual.
The claim is merely the
unsurprising one that growing
up in circumstances where your
attention is, as a matter of
course, directed in particular
ways, will lead you exactly in
the ways that Aristotle
suggested, to find those ways
of responding to be natural
and habitual.
So what I want to do in the
closing five minutes of the
lecture is to give you a final
example from the WEIRD paper.
To run you through some of the
cases on which the claim that
Americans stand out relative
to other westerners on
phenomena that are associated
with independent self-concept
and individualism is based.
So these are all clicker
questions.
And they are a series of survey
questions that, at
least 15 years ago, typically
produced very different
responses in North American
educated subjects than they
did in citizens of other
Western and non-Western
industrialized nations.
In particular, different
responses among Americans than
they produced among Germans or
Australians or Japanese.
So I'm just going to give you
a series of questions.
We're going to see how your
numbers come out.
And we'll compare them to how
those data looked in the
original studies.
So here's your first question.
"While you are talking and
sharing a bottle of beer"--
I know none of you would ever do
this, this is something to
imagine for when you grow up--
"when you are talking and
sharing a bottle of beer with
a friend who is officially on
duty as a safety controller in
the company where you both
work, an accident occurs
injuring a shift worker.
An investigation is launched
by the national safety
commission and you are asked
for your evidence.
There are no other witnesses.
What right has your friend to
expect you to protect him?
A, a definite right.
B, some right.
D, no right." So investigating
commission, do you protect
your friend?
Let's see how the numbers
come out.
8% of you think there
is a definite right.
48% of you think there
is some right.
And 44% of you think
there is no right.
OK let's see whether we can get
these numbers up again.
Gosh, OK, I was going to show
you how your numbers compare
to the traditional numbers
that were ascertained.
What I'm going to do is leave
these slides up for you as
always and you can go and
check the comparison.
The idea is that in the original
studies, Americans
showed, 94% of them in this
column, you show 92% of you in
the two of these.
Whereas if you looked across
other countries, people gave
different answers.
The claim is not that one or the
other of these outlooks is
a legitimate one.
The claim is just to alert you
to the fact that there are
radical differences in how
people think about the world.
Let's try the next one.
So I don't know why we've
got the reveal here.
So don't pay no attention to the
numbers that appear here.
Do you think "that only
real goal of a company
is to make a profit?
Or do you think B, that a
company, besides making a
profit has the goal of attaining
the well-being of
various stakeholders such as
employees, stockholders and
others?" Your numbers suggest
a tendency to think that it
has other goals as well.
But 33% of you think the only
goal of a company is profit.
Among Japanese citizens surveyed
in 1993, only 8% sat
where 33% of you sit.
"If you apply for a job in a
company," is your thought,
"one, that you will almost
certainly work there for the
rest of your life?" Or is your
thought that "you are almost
sure that the relationship will
have a limited duration?"
Let's see how these look.
8% of you think you will
work there for the
rest of your life.
92% percent, limited duration.
By contrast, if you look at the
numbers here, you are with
the Americans.
60% of Japanese asked that
similar question gave the
answer that you did.
Over and over and over again--
and I'll leave you three more
examples on the slide
to look at--
you see that whatever it
is that you are like --
if you are like the Japanese
with 41% you were different
from the Americans, if you were
like the Americans with
99%, you were different
than the Japanese --
the cultural environment in
which you find yourself plays
a role in determining
your outlook.
And we'll begin next lecture
with an acceleration of a
particular version of this in
the context of Cass Sunstein's
discussion of social norms.
Let me remind you that Thursday
is Bulldog day.
And if possible, if as many of
you as can will sit over on
this side of the room to leave
seats for our visiting
students, that would be
much appreciated.